in a funny way they're not just movies
to me it was a way of expressing emotion
and a way of learning a little about
life you need to know how ideas and
emotions are expressed through a visual
form certain tools you use and those
tools become part of a vocabulary that's
just as valid as that vocabulary that is
used in literature i mean in cinema
we're working with subtleties as a
curtain that blows a certain way in the
frame and an actor shifts his eyes a
certain way it had to be an emotional
connection
to the material and to the characters
um the obsessiveness of travis pickle
the sense of being the outsider and not
being the dispossessed that's how you
know we felt that way but over the years
i was more drawn to um the films that i
that i
constantly revisited or
saw repeatedly held up longer for me
over the years
not because of plot but because of
character
and um
a very different approach to story in
the process of making the picture i
tried to learn about myself learn about
life we try to find the truth in those
things and because the truth is is uh
enjoyable and painful and a lot of fun
[Music]
you know but i think what we're really
talking about is it's not just movies
that they're not just movies to me there
in many respects
uh having had asthma my father take him
to the movie theater constantly because
he couldn't i couldn't play sports or
anything
he never really talked to me very much
when i was a kid and so that was a way
of talking that was a way of of
experiencing
strong emotional whether it's whether it
was kirk douglas and lana turner and the
bed and the beautiful or was james mason
the desert fox or was uh
on the town or american in paris uh you
know any of these things it was a way of
experiencing emotion of feelings if i
wanted to say i loved you to him which i
didn't it was through that film you see
and same way with him to me and my
mother to a certain extent also my older
brother too and so in a funny way
they're not just movies to me it was a
way of expressing emotion and a way of
learning a little about life and uh
using these as examples um
of how to live or
you can't take not every film what i
mean by that is that it's like um
it becomes about life
the pictures i make i'm talking about it
becomes about the fact that yes i adore
these old movies and everything because
i could never make them
i wish i could have but i not i'm what i
am i do what i do now
and in the process of making the picture
i try to
learn about myself learn about life and
it uh
we try to find the truth in those things
and because the truth is is enjoyable
and painful and a lot of fun
i mean in
cinema we're working with subtleties as
a curtain that blows a certain way in
the frame and an actor shifts his eyes a
certain way another one does something
that's unexpected with our hands let's
say there are silences pauses thoughts
even shivers you know
the great
silent uh film master fw morneau uh once
said that in cinema we were dealing with
quote uh the most fleeting harmonies of
atmosphere unquote so atmosphere is very
important
that includes sound
and we're dealing with human events in
that atmosphere with being in the frame
how a person moves and changes
there's nothing generic about a close-up
or a long shot because every take is
really
distinct and completely different on its
own what do you do when you when you
change how
the world
thinks of cinema
[Music]
what's next i mean um
do you keep making the same kind of film
or if you're a person like russellini uh
if you are
you try something experimental you push
further it's not just experimental for
experiment experiments sake but you push
the boundaries further i
kind of think as an editor myself really
when i make pictures i'm planning a film
i'm seeing come together in my mind
but
whenever that happens i'm really
thinking more of the flow of images
juxtaposition of images actually the
cuts
really now one affects the other i kind
of anticipate
a feeling of wonder and excitement that
i always have
whenever i go into the editing room
i have this
excitement about seeing and
feeling what happens
when you take one image
and another image
not the same uh
but you put the two together
and it creates some sort of sensation a
kind of uh
spark but really these two disparate
images spliced together create
what i like to call a phantom image
which is in the mind's eye
emotion psychology
political
you make your point through that cut
in a sense having said that you could
take
i don't know you could take that same
cut you can remove one frame at the tail
of the first shot and add two frames on
the tail the second and it's completely
different a sensation a completely
different
phantom image
in the mind is created and that's the
mystery and
uh the beauty of
really the heart of cinema for me
it's always what has compelled me to
make pictures always will be
what compels me to make a film you know
people always say well interested in the
antagonist in my movies well the point
is that they're also human these are
also parts of the negative parts of who
they are
evil streak so to speak if you want to
use that phrase
there's also
maybe something in us and something not
to be afraid of but to explore a lot of
his films and especially with goodfellas
definitely deal in the underworld and
that's been a recurring theme in a lot
of
his work and i think people are
attracted to that but more so the fact
that
he's always
trying to grasp the humanity of these
people the flawed nature of these
characters i think they just reflect
aspects of who we are as human beings
and some things we can't deny
or pretend they don't exist
that's the idea
that's very dangerous because when it if
you're teaching younger people when they
suddenly shock to find out it does exist
no it exists
you know i just want to get you prepared
i don't know how it's going to come at
you but it's going to be there because
that's part of who we are one has to
begin to i think
reach younger people
at an earlier age
for them to
to
shape
their minds to in critical way
a critical way of looking at these
images and what they mean and how to
interpret
imagery
um
and i think um in a more official way i
think than than uh just punching up on a
computer or seeing something on a tv
commercial or something like that i
think it really i think you really need
to know you need to know how
ideas and emotions are expressed
through a visual form i come from a
working class family my mother and
father weren't well educated um
um
i was second generation i guess
italian-american
um and uh there were there was no
tradition of reading in the house no
books um of course i read in school etc
books in school and that sort of thing
but there was more of a visual tradition
more uh if
i was taken to movie theaters a lot so
it was mainly mainly uh
um
visual literacy what was was what was
happening at at that time to me i did
not understand that that was happening
what it made me realize was that there
was an intelligence another kind of
intelligence that was trying to tell a
story through where
the director the writer and the
cinematographer
where they were focusing your eyes
you know whether it was the camera may
be in an extremely low angle
looking up at you um
the use of the lens the size of the lens
i began to understand certain lenses
did interpreted
the story differently
a longer lens crushed everything
together and made it flat
a wider lens stretched everything and
some don't distort it but i was
beginning to understand
that certain tools you use and those
tools
uh become part of a vocabulary
that's just as valid as that vocabulary
that is used in literature and so film
is very
powerful
images are very powerful i should say we
have to start begin to teach younger
people how to use them
and what they and at least to begin to
understand to interpret them do you want
to be famous did you want to be oh yeah
yeah absolutely yes and did all that
generation of people that you met then
yes spielberg and trader and we all did
i mean when i was at nyu i know i was a
director
i was making a living editing somewhat
other people's films and and
documentaries and things like that i was
making a living also doing a little bit
of writing but basically no i felt i was
a director and i i knew i was when other
people didn't take me that seriously
and
i went to a shameless i went to every
party in l.a i promoted myself
shamelessly
make your own industry
recreate movies
don't pay attention industry do your own
thing
i mean
put it this way
you want the work to be seen
but it doesn't have to be the odeon
you know
no more that's all different that's all
god's another ancient world
that type of film or not even that type
of film the
the the communal experience is always
important you can make a film on a
camera the size of that doorknob and
still show it to uh 1 600 people in an
audience it's still a great communal
experience you know it doesn't
necessarily mean it has to cost
over 100 million
pounds you know it's all new you just
break it open break open the form don't
just uh
just you know have your tripod and a
camera that's standing on it
the cameras that are being made now and
of course the fact that all
our aeroflex and other cameras have
stopped being made
and whether we like it or not we have to
deal with a new new
technology
high definition
or digital whatever it's called it's it
it changes cinematography the artichoke
the cinematographer but but
you younger ones you make a new art
take what's available push it
you know
because it's going to go there you could
do anything well you must see lots of
scripts when the script comes across
your desk and you uh you look at what's
the hallmark of a great script how do
you know you want to choose that one
over the thousands or hundreds of others
that you look at what
personal or personal usually i don't
read other people's scripts and i
usually develop something or
um i have something in mind and i work
with a friend usually in uh in some
cases nick pelechi in other cases jaycox
or hire paul schrader for uh bringing
out the dead but when for example when
taxi driver was given to me to read by
brian de palma
um i hadn't done mean streets yet and so
but he said you'd be great for this and
automatically i mean there had to be an
emotional connection to the material and
to the characters
um the obsessiveness of travis pickle
the sense of being the outsider and not
being the dispossessed that's how you
know we felt that way i mean myself and
i could speak for de niro to a certain
extent because we didn't articulate it
that way i can't really say oh you know
we're outsiders we were trying to get in
we're trying to stay in hollywood good
fellows was very special
i was looking for something that
i could find another way of dealing with
genre and i think really that's what
started to get me really interested in
the characters in the world that it
depicted in a genre that i've kind of
felt most comfortable with over the
years there's something about the
underworld has more to do with the kind
of
a working class or lower working class
existence from
where i come from and so it's natural
for me that world is something that
deals with very basic conflicts basic
dilemmas moral dilemmas that i grew up
with and so i feel comfortable with it
there's something about de niro who
understands the humanity
of
all kinds of people
and could really
uh express that
we had some similar interests he knew
where i came from i knew where he came
from he understood the area i grew up in
and i just think that they reflect those
dilemmas those conflicts it's kind of
comfortable at times to to do stuff that
you feel you
intrinsically know
what i mean is
no at least in terms of
body language
um
dialogue
no dialogue we shot most of the film in
35 millimeter
uh but for the night scenes we use the
alexa which is the new hd cameras i mean
they're able to see things to actually
see things
that film cameras simply can't but kind
of take it for granted i think uh
because the post is almost infinite you
can color you could do any color light
framing you could reframe you could
alter speed uh
you can alter elements in the same frame
take a character from one take and put
them in another take i imagine how
all of this would have felt too all of
this new stuff would have felt to david
david lean to king vidor thoreau
dickinson imagine what they would have
done with these tools all these choices
that's sometimes not a great thing to
have all these choices you know
limitation is good often really is
these choices could be infinite
uh
would the tools
have changed their art right well
yes
in every way i suppose
i mean even if it did and i'm sure it
would have they would have reflected
their own time
in completely different ways
than the films that they made
as filmmakers we all make use of
whatever tools we have
and
when we do utilize those tools we can
only really speak in the time in which
we live and we have no choice there i
often think about these questions and
for the younger filmmakers i know and
admiring joachim trier and joanna hogg
ariester
christie puyu
so many others
in effect they've had these tools
i believe they've had these tools around
them all the time
so how does it feel to them
it's quite different than it does to me
i think you've said
that
film a film can become an obsession with
you yes and i know that's true
and you said and so you've lost certain
things without being without meaning to
be presumptuous
what sacrifices do you think you've made
in order
to create the work to make the films to
make the career that you've done what do
you think in your life you've sacrificed
i think you know as an old friend no
priest told me he said you pay a price
you know and you pay a price
just quite honestly you know a personal
life really and uh relationships go by
the board i mean
it was as if um the frank capra quote
it's like being like a drug or something
that you have to continue and now as i
say some people call that drive some
call it obsession some call it just
being selfish and being not a very nice
person but the reality is that um
i just had to
continue that process you've made it
clear that you're big on story but not
big on plot and i'd like you to just
talk about the difference between story
and plot if you would i just found that
over the years i was more drawn to
the films that i that i
constantly revisited or or
saw repeatedly held up longer for me
over the years
not because of plot but because of
character
and
a very different approach to story you
know
just for example talk about hitchcock
and we we
see his films in the 50s as they came
out
strangers on a train rear window all the
way up to uh you know vertigo
north by northwest and into psycho but i
think over the years the films of
hitchcock that i enjoy watching
repeatedly
uh the wrong man for example as a
picture that i i've used repeatedly as
an example of um
mood
paranoid style
uh beautiful new york uh um location
photography paranoid camera moves uh the
feelings of threat uh when uh if you
know the picture henry fonda has to go
to the uh
to pay uh panas insurance uh in queens i
i was i was i grew up a little bit i
grew up until about seven years old and
queen sold me to jamaica and that whole
area so
it was kind of interesting to see it but
he's standing behind the encounter and
the woman is looking over and she you
see henry fonda from her point of view
and she thinks he's a robber because he
had just robbed this place earlier and
she thinks he's come back uh and the way
the camera moves her perception
excellent excellent excellent bit part
players because they can they could kill
you if you don't get the right person
the fear the anxiety the paranoia it's
all done through the camera and the
person's face is the same
i find i find that that is more
interesting to me so when i when i i saw
rebecca maybe 10 times 14 times and
everything but at a certain point i said
i know
there's no for me the style hitchcock in
that film is only in the sequence when
mrs danvers
shows the um uh
rebecca's room to joan fontaine
that's about it for the rest of it i
know the plot is it's not interesting
anymore so for somebody who has a vision
like marty to get other people because
you've got to get other people to do it
with you who are on the same frequencies
who understand what you're looking for
who share the vision and then can make
it happen
that's priceless yeah that really is
that's the struggle too yeah because it
is collaborative if i could shoot it and
if i could edit it myself and if i could
write it if i could act in it fine but i
can't you know so you need people who
are like-minded and away or exploring
certain areas that you want to go to
possibly at a certain point in your life
nero is standing at the bar with a
cigarette and he's looking at manny and
he's gonna kill him and you know he's
gonna kill him and marty has this shot
and he gets closer and closer and closer
and bob's eyes get more wolf-like it was
just the most terrifying picture and as
i'm typing that stuff because i'm the
typist he says put in cream put in cream
i said what cream says just right write
down cream i said what's what cream what
are you talking about just put it just
put it put it do me a favor just put it
so i typed in cream well it turns out
while we're typing that scene he's
already listening to the music they were
they there was no tradition of reading
in the house no books
um of course etc books in school and
that sort of thing but there was more of
a visual tradition more uh if
i was taken to movie theaters a lot uh
also being a sickly child with
very severe asthma i couldn't play
sports so again the movie theater movie
theater in the church the church in the
movie theater and so
along with the films uh there was also
the advent of television 1948-49 and the
heyday of
really the best some of the best
programming in american television in
the history of american television up to
this point was the 50s 1950s
and so i saw a lot of television shows
but also
films on television
being working class family too
they didn't have enough money to go to
the theater so theater wasn't an option
live stage shows so it was mainly mainly
uh
um
visual literacy what was was what was
happening at at that time to me i did
not understand that that was happening
what it made me realize was that there
was an intelligence another kind of
intelligence that was trying to tell a
story through where
the director the writer and the
cinematographer
where they were focusing your eyes
you know whether the camera may be in an
extremely low angle
looking up at you um
the use of the lens the size of the lens
and began to understand certain lenses
did interpreted the story differently
a longer lens crushed everything
together and made it flat
a wider lens stretched everything and
sometimes distorted it especially if
camera movement
i learned looking at certain pictures
particularly wells films and and william
weiler too a wide angle lens
the while wiler used his wide angle lens
in a very strong steady image but wells
used that wide-angle lens 18 millimeter
it turns out
very often to move along walls move
along and you really felt i felt as if
the camera was flying as if the story
was flying by you know
i didn't know why
until i kept seeing the films again and
again and as i began to
know a little more about what filmmaking
was like and what cameras did and
that's i still didn't know who made the
pictures you know
but i was beginning to understand that
there are certain
certain tools you use and those tools
become part of a vocabulary
that's just as valid as that vocabulary
that is used in literature in our
language what is it about this thing of
filmmaking that turns you most
what is it about this process
um that
you know is it the editing is it
creating the scene for me for me if
first of all you need you need the story
you need the script to be there you need
the script to be there you needed to be
on the page in terms of the emotion and
in terms of uh something with which the
audience can empathize in terms of
characters you need the audience to care
about somebody okay that's one thing so
we've been taking over the years we've
been pushing we're pushing the envelope
on that though over the years with mean
streets taxi driver raging bull and
particularly raging bull and even
goodfellas and casinos so you're pushing
the edge there how much can you care for
a person if he's this bad or she's that
bad you know can you still care there's
someone there i know can still care so
that's pretty good okay now let's see if
we can push a little more i have to like
the people in the film i have to love
them the characters or the actors
both actually yeah
both first i start with the characters
and um if you have actors who are who
are soul mates too that's great i also
have the same philosophy too uh de niro
has a certain philosophy kaitel
and it's the same place that you have
it's a shared philosophy yeah it is
which is well
dealing with the subject matter that we
see a certain way and there's a certain
truth that we try to get to
uh joe pesci too has that about the
about a raging bull or about uh about a
good fellas or a casino uh that we just
sense when something isn't quite right
we know that that gesture is wrong you
know uh you can't direct it they have to
they have to be it people who are flawed
people
like ourselves
and to see if anybody else cares about
them yeah the violence that i that i
have in my pictures um and again you
know be self-criticized people say sure
you know the kind of violence you do you
think is all right but if anybody else
does it you're you're criticizing them
but what we're talking about the
violence in my films is not pleasant
you you reap what you sow
in the in the stories i'm trying to tell
and i don't know any other way to show
it
and and and there's also
to deal with the very very dangerous
aspect of um
that adrenaline one has is young that
that could be uh
it could be um
expressed many different ways
and some sort of excitement whether it's
sexual excitement or violence or
whatever there's that there's that
danger that one has to know that's part
of what it is being human especially
young and that could go wrong and when
it goes wrong this could happen
now the world i came from the world i
knew or all aspects i should say of the
world i knew a lot of
it was a valid form of expression that's
the world
that's the world i'm
that's the human condition that is the
human condition and it's tragic and and
it's it's set up in such a way that will
it will do us in as a species if we
don't learn about it
i don't put it up there for people to
enjoy it you know and if they are
enjoying it they catch themselves
enjoying it
and the characters
pay for it i love to watch my son direct
region what is one of the greatest tell
me what i don't like i don't like when
he puts me in a picture and then he
takes me out
well that's not fair all the whole scene
in kingdom comedy with the de niro down
in the basement and his mother arguing
with them is all improvised between the
two very good i i thought of that all
myself
all by myself
and uh
he gave me two words and he says
continue yeah right
she wrote it um wrote down her own
dialogue when he wait a minute when he
when he started when he started with
these films and he used to tell me
you have to get in the picture
i used to tell him but i'm not an
actress he seems to say to me but you
don't have to be an actress i said but i
don't know how to act he says mother you
either get in the picture or you pay
money i didn't have so i had to get in
the picture
pay for what
for the actress for the actors
we had no money so i had to get in the
picture tell me how to use me how much
you got for your pot
main streets they gave me 28 and i
couldn't say nothing 28
these are the questions that
you have to deal with if you're making a
film to anyone who decides what you're
leaving the frame and what you leave out
and that that's the fundamental issue
where do you put the camera which take
do you use where do you where you cut or
not cut that's the basic question
now we come full circle to the irishman
you know working with the actors trying
to capture again
kind of a beauty of movement
gesture speech
a lot of stuff i recall from my own life
growing up
and that i could
really explore further with you know
incredible artists like pacino and de
niro albertus and i worked was the first
time we were together on this picture
and bob and i returned to working
together again after
i think the last picture we worked on
together was a casino 1995.
so this took a long time to find the
right project
and to
find the right space so to speak in
which we could operate
and also try to learn more about
ourselves i guess i'm not sure
it may be about
making a movie you know
and we're looking even more closely from
this vantage point in our lives at the
age of 75 76 we're looking at friendship
betrayal
power
trust self-preservation
and then maybe
a possibility of a redemption
i think
i know at least in my case we all return
to what obsesses us what haunts us
to the questions that
deepen and
really become more mysterious as time
goes by as we ask them
you